I need to place a rather large order
basically one of every food item there
so like one of every sandwich one of
every side
breakfast and lunch everything today's
very special day I'm doing the every
food at McDonald's taste test
I should be picking up 60 things that's
a lot it's plentiful now I'm gonna try
everything in McDonald's you'll be able
to know which one's the best and which
one's the least best the worst you want
to hear an interesting anecdote yeah so
I used to work in a chemical lab right
and so one of my co-workers used to work
in a factory
[Music]
McDonald's don't be eight three I have a
very large order coming in are you ready
all right I want one big mac one
cheeseburger one quarter pounder with
cheese signature sriracha then the peak
of guacamole burger
do you like McDonald's McDonald's okay I
like their chicken stuff I don't like
the burgers as much but that's because
when I was a kid I had some include oh
yes I Rutten yogurt parfait
and I think that's it
I'm under five
Wow all that for $105 is actually what a
deal also eight cars have piled up
behind me since I started that order
thank you very much
Wow they showed up with a box and little
drinks I didn't order coffee right
you know maybe they just felt bad for me
maybe they're like he's gonna need some
help pushing this out let's give him
some coffee I would say like oh well I'm
lactose intolerant I don't want to upset
my stomach but I'm eating everything at
McDonald's that 60 bites of any food is
too much food 60 orders too many oysters
60 doughnuts too many doughnuts it's
just too much but you know I'm trying to
stay positive
[Music]
let's do this
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so this is everything at McDonald's
not everything on the menu because they
didn't have everything but I ordered
everything that I could except that I
forgot french fries so I'm gonna go back
and get those but right now we have
enough McDonald's to start with I think
we should start with the lazy eye a fish
sandwich last night it wasn't that good
this was better than that that was a
real restaurant so good job McDonald's
one done good fish
yum yum let's move on to the double
quarter-pounder with cheese a signature
burger of McDonald's hmm it's a little
more meat than I liked but some people
like a lot of me that's the thing that I
threw up after eating once and it
doesn't make me nauseous anymore
the big man what is it the real star
here phille nuggets this is the
traditional boot shape I have ranch
sweet and sour whoa look at the size of
this chicken is coming out of the
sandwich oh yes here we go there's some
crispy fried onion strings look around
his box
what burger are you signature sriracha
artisan roll very spicy
I taste nothing but heat oh my god my
body just trying the food there's the
beat go groans take a sandwich to
skywalk I'm always sort of on it and I
guess I'm supposed to squeeze lemon on
it so I'm gonna whoa this is the best
thing I've had the quality of my voice
get thicker there's only enough grease
on my throat that my voice has changed
holy [ __ ] salad grilled chicken
Southwest salad not bad salad let's give
the body a treat let's have some apples
huh my body thinks it tastes even better
than normal I think oh let's have some
breakfast shall we I'm gonna say this is
back relax no I'm not because this guy
won't taste as good later I'm gonna eat
it right now everybody loves the hash
brown it's perfect this is the best
thing we can get at McDonald's big
breakfast thing the bacon is on the
pancake so I'm gonna leave them on the
pancakes oh so sweet
hey cakes aren't great pancakes you
can't really [ __ ] them up English muffin
mmm not crispy at all how did they make
it look like it was crispy it looks
crispy right it's not it's so pillowy so
pillowy so pillowy mm-hmm
I'm not really supposed to eat eggs but
I'm also not supposed to eat 60 things
in McDonald's so you know what's the
worst that could happen
oh I won't race you to eggy absolutely
I'm not really supposed to eat
blueberries or dairy the hot fudge is
[ __ ] delicious
it's good but it's like an assault of
sugar oh I had 32 different things not
really though because they didn't give
me salads they doubled up one of my
breakfast sandwiches but my mind is very
foggy case of the post Thanksgivings you
know this is sort of where we are I kind
of enjoyed everything I'm just kind of
blown right I haven't had fries by the
end of the video I'm gonna eat fries I
just I don't know what to do five six 27
- 28 only 28
there's way more things than that I
wanted 60 of them there's only 28 oh god
we more calling Zach hey boy so much
what are you guys up to
you want some McDonald's
I was about to go get a salad oh I've
got a I've got I've got salads I think
you just need to come now just put up
the bat-signal
he's got a lot of McDonald's and he
needs some help are you guys ready let's
go here are the things that I ordered it
was only 28 things that means you should
be able to eat this all by yourself
benefits only half well it's yeah well
and then I forgot french fries and I'm
an idiot I feel like an idiot I know I
know
I feel like our first mission should be
to finish all this food if we can finish
this food then you can order more but I
don't want to be wait I don't want to
just order more food when we have best
food yeah well you do need fries though
time for lunch okay
I don't remember taking that bite can
you see can you see space and time Bruce
my vision is kind of fuzzy let's load
this up into a cart and just take it
around the office that's what I think we
need to do I like bottles dim sum do you
want some McDonald's why why are you
doing
do you want to grab something I think
you're gonna have to you know my shop
just making you hungry not charming
enough Eugene what you get that looks
questionable don't worry about that but
spreading happiness this is a huge fight
up spreading joy we're making a dent in
this guys happy birthday Wow Keith you
know at the beginning of this day I
think we all had our doubts but you
really spread enjoy and the look on
people's faces you did a good thing we
gave everybody a gift today
yes um and dance I think the lesson the
big takeaway here is don't do this yeah
you shouldn't try to eat everything at a
restaurant you should just pick one
thing but I did learn what was the best
thing there and it was the Pico grilled
chicken signature sandwich
thanks for watching our vlog it was a
vlog until next time I farted when I did
that I think pop culture is a social
construct everyone knows that viral
media is just opiate of the masses
I like BuzzFeed before the try guys so
over this just can't wait till I leave
this small town Los Angeles moved to
Sweden fed jet life the irony is not
lost on me
I reject commercialism but I love Harry
Potter so lit so it's another day but I
just went to McDonald's and got all the
other stuff I don't know sixteen or
twenty things you bet I'm not gonna give
up on this I'm gonna taste the rest of
this stuff so we're gonna go eat it it's
just me it's just me and food so we're
gonna do this as quick as we can quick
and painless baby Coca Cola french fries
the most important thing that I forgot
hmm all right good there aren't as good
you think you know that rise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
some happiness
[Music]